avez-vous déjà manqué à votre employeur
alors j'ai les réponses de chacun par
exemple Valérie bénanime m'a dit non bah
non mon ami donc
Daniel Moreau
j'ai dit que j'étais malade ou des trucs
comme ça
Jean-Marie Bigard a dit non bravo
Jean-Marie bravo
je vous parle de ma personne vous
Hanouna
extrêmement sévère Gilles Verdez
la tentation vous devineriez que c'est
un mensonge donc je n'essaierai pas et
oui avant j'ai menti oui Clément tu m'as
déjà menti
deux trois détails
on est pas bien
est-ce que pas le dire c'est mentir bien
sûr omettre au mec c'est pareil
au mec voilà
commentez au niveau de la langue
française et comment tu sais comment ah
non c'est juste pour savoir comment
réussir la même chose au mec oui
bah c'est bien
sûr
Géraldine bien sûr n'a jamais jamais
bravo Géraldine je vous offre une autre
côte ce soir Castaldi a déjà menti à moi
oui
déjà mais si je vous ai dit que j'étais
pas là parce que je devais dire j'étais
malade j'étais parti à Los Angeles je
suis revenu immédiatement
combien de fois avez-vous été arrêté par
la police zéro fort avez-vous déjà fait
vos besoins dans un lieu public oui j'ai
fait pipi une fois
dans ta vie tu as fait pipi sur
l'autoroute et le temps je me suis
arrêté sur le on doit pas le faire sur
la bande d'arrêt d'urgence mais vraiment
j'en pouvais plus donc de derrière la
portière pipi quoi mais tout le monde le
fait tout le temps ça non pas tout le
temps
fréquence vous rendez vous dans un lieu
de culte par mois qui a répondu à Benaim
tu as mis tu as mis quoi jamais par moi
non j'y vais pour les grandes fêtes mais
j'y vais pas tous les mois
Daniel Moreau une fois bah en moyenne
mais c'est vrai que dès que je vais dans
un aller prier toi pour trouver vas-y
toutes les semaines
Jean-Marie Bigard ah quatre fois par
mois
je compte surtout les dimanches quoi la
messe d'accord c'est vous vous êtes
choqué non c'est bon non non mais c'est
vrai une fois
par mois
vous allez à l'église vous êtes déjà à
l'église
[Rires]
figurez-vous tiens Gilles Verdez jamais
Véro
là
tu vas où parce que en revanche par
exemple j'ai déjà fait mes besoins dans
un lieu public régulièrement là j'aurais
répondu oui mais
si c'est un reproche il est fondé je ne
vais pas assez à la mosquée je vais
essayer d'y aller plus fais gaffe salut
je vais vérifier non je vais essayer d'y
aller plus bien sûr je vérifié
Guillaume Genton
Guillaume avez-vous déjà une relation
sexuelle au travail oui
ah pourquoi bah régulièrement quoi avec
qui mais à quelle heure
on s'entend bien avec quelqu'un au
travail c'est normal de
Ken dans la bonne humeur
[Rires]
avec quelqu'un qu'on connaît atpmp
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Luc de la compta
ou la partenaire d'une amie oui quoi oui
[Applaudissements]
lors de soirée un peu
[Musique]
oui des copines par exemple Géraldine tu
as le droit de reparler j'aime bien
jouez-vous à des jeux d'argent par mois
Daniel 4 fois ou plus jouer au loto
toutes les semaines
pas gagné
[Applaudissements]
sur son truc
Gilbert est d'abord non non toi tu as
jamais rien du tout non mais tu es un
taré toi vous arrive-t-il de parler dans
le dos de vos collègues non
jamais avez-vous déjà une relation
sexuelle au travail non avez-vous déjà
trompé votre partenaire non tu as une
vie de merde
franchement avez-vous déjà eu une
exploration sexuelle tarifée non alors
tu es menteur je pense que tu es menteur
je viens de comprendre
cette compagne beaucoup de choses le nez
il est fou
je te le dis non mais j'ai répondu oui à
exhiber vos parties alors
franchement
tu vois pas avec vous déjà couché on va
c'est le ou la partenaire d'un ami ou
d'une amie non non frère
là je suis sur Raymond par contre il y a
des oui partout
[Applaudissements]
de parler dans le dos de vos collègues
oui vous avez-vous déjà eu une relation
sexuelle au travail
votre partenaire oui avez-vous déjà une
relation sexuelle tarif et oui arrête
les deux il y a pas les deux derniers
c'est pas les deux avantages
mais j'étais là
[Applaudissements]
ton pote dans le croit mais bon c'est
ton temps
Raymond c'est Cyril tu me remets bah oui
qui a payé allez viens tu as pas quelque
chose à me dire dans l'oreille
moi j'ai dit j'ai dit la vérité sur le
test
change pas des réponses
parce que malheureusement je connais la
vérité
j'ai répondu moi c'est bien
Castaldi
bon alors lui voilà
alors lui que des mauvaises réponses à
quelle fréquence vous rendez vous dans
un lieu de culte jamais et après il
s'étonne de ne pas avoir de chance
avez-vous déjà volé oui
[Rires]
avez-vous déjà activé vos parties
génitales dans un lieu public oui mais
personne l'a vu
avez-vous déjà trompé votre partenaire
oui à vous déjà une relation sexuelle
tarif et oui bien sûr avez-vous déjà
couché embrasser le partenaire d'un ami
oui Castaldi sachez que vous êtes le
pire
note c'est Castaldi la plus pure c'est
belaïm oh pure c'est Castaldi
franchement
tu peux répondre
c'est de la merde ce test
avez-vous déjà menti à votre employeur
alors donc je vous le faites chez vous
également avez-vous déjà menti avec eux
ceux qui ont dit oui ça sera trois
points pour moi d'accord combien de fois
avez-vous été arrêté par la police
tu vas pas commencer à me reprendre ça
va me faire chier
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait vos
besoins dans un lieu
publics
moi je peux faire le guide du duieur
il fait toujours du papier toilette
aussi dans la voiture j'ai les deux
d'abord parce que quand c'est humide
vous inquiétez pas c'est la première
fois
j'ai pas un champignon dans les fesses
c'est important alors à quelle fréquence
vous rendez vous dans un lieu de culte
par mois
donc vous vous êtes quatre fois ou plus
ça fait 0 point pour ceux qui nous
regardent c'est trois fois c'est un
point deux fois c'est trois points une
fois c'est 5 points et jamais c'est 7
points est-ce que vous avez déjà volé
Cyril
oui peut-être une fois pas mal
un magasin un proche ou un inconnu
c'est combien de points
un magasin 4 points un inconnu trois
points
ok
est-ce que ça vous est-ce que vous
parlez dans le dos des gens maintenant
par mois pas beaucoup
pour les gens c'est zéro point pour
jamais un point pour une fois trois
points pour deux 5 points pour quatre
fois et plus de 80
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que les gens veulent hein
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu une
relation sexuelle au travail
[Rires]
je crois que je vais quitter l'émission
Bon ben oui mais oui
avez-vous déjà exhibé vos parties
génitales
avez-vous déjà trompé votre partenaire
à base il y a que des oui à la fin ok
d'accord 5 points pour oui mais bon très
bien vous avez déjà une relation
sexuelle tarifs
que vous avez déjà couché ou embrasser
la partenaire
[Applaudissements]
il comprend la question ce qui vous
concerne je crois Jean-Michel maire
de planning
toi tu devrais te faire tout petit mais
non mais juste embrassé vous avez
peut-être envie du bout des lèvres quoi
un gage alors faut savoir que le mec qui
est quand même non plus pote avec moi
dans l'émission avec Guillaume c'est
Raymond tu as l'air de m'accablir
les cinq dernières elles devraient même
pas exister question fais gaffe à toi
parce que non non je rigole voilà rigole
que entre 0 et 20 points vous étiez une
personne pure entre 21 et 40 vous étiez
une personne humaine avec cet effet
voilà et au-delà de 40 41 c'était une
personne immonde allez vous faire
soigner en l'occurrence vous vous avez
30 points vous êtes humains
je ne suis qu'un homme